neuer ärger um impfstoff thüringen
vergibt keine neuen impftermine mehr
weil astrazeneca vor lieferproblemen
warnt wahlen in corona zeiten mit einem
briefwahl boom in baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz startet deutschland ins
superwahljahr und olympia vor augen nach
einem sieg gegen slowenien haben die
deutschen handballer beste chancen auf
die teilnahme in tokio
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten abend
hinein an diesem samstag um 7 sport
nachher in der sendung mit norbert
lehmann ein stück von mir das impfen in
deutschland ist weiterhin kompliziert
die ersten bundesländer melden sogar
rückschritte weil der hersteller
astrazeneca drastische lieferprobleme
angekündigt hat das robert koch institut
warnt unterdessen vor einem neuen schub
von infektionen in deutschland zu ostern
aktuell sieht die lage laut den haag
zahlen so aus
innerhalb eines tages wurden zwölf 1674
neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind 3117
mehr als vor einer woche
239 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus
und auch die inzidenz steigt weiter auf
aktuell 76,1 anselm stern berichtet
impfzentrum erfurt am nachmittag
thüringen hat die schlechtesten virus
zahlen in deutschland heute kommt eine
neue schlechte nachricht obendrauf
astrazeneca liefert weniger heißt hier
die vergabe von neuen impfterminen wird
gestoppt das ist eine katastrophe weil
viele menschen gerade in gebieten in
denen hohe infektionsraten gibt auf die
impfung warten
wir müssen aber unser großes im zentrum
in gera jetzt schließen es soll deutlich
mehr impfstoff in deutschland produziert
werden das land solle sich im kommenden
jahr selbst versorgen können so der neue
impfte auftrag der bundesregierung zu
den gewaltigen schwierigkeiten der zeit
sagt er dass impfstoffproduktion ist
eine schwierige sache dass er werden wir
damit leben müssen dass wir gute
nachrichten haben wie zb die nachricht
dass biontech jetzt mehr produzieren
kann als vorher und dafür auch schlechte
nachrichten haben dass astrazeneca nicht
so weit ist noch nicht weit gekommen ist
deutschland auf dem weg raus aus dem
coro natal denn die zahl der
neuinfektionen steigt wieder spürbar
wowi anstiege sehen sind bei den
jüngeren bis hin zu den 60 jährigen das
heißt es ist doch natürlich der
vermehrte kontakt und ich befürchte ein
bisschen schon die variante die
britische die ja inzwischen bei uns fast
60 prozent einnimmt
und so steigt auch die
sogenannte sieben tage inzidenz an auf
jetzt 76 schon an ostern könnte alles
wieder so sein wie an weihnachten sagt
jetzt ein rechenmodell des robert koch
instituts und der erfahrung aus anderen
ländern zu befürchten dass wenn wir
jetzt nichts tun nicht gegensteuern und
weiter lockern würden dass uns die
zahlen letztendlich um die ohren fliegen
und sich diese modellrechnung mit
irgendwie 30.000 neuinfizierten zu
ostern pro tag dass sich die
bewahrheiten werden schwierige lage also
in fast allen bereichen dieser virus
krise noch recht gut bei den
neuinfektionen steht mecklenburg
vorpommern derzeit da und macht sich
daher umso mehr sorgen beim blick ins
benachbarte polen
dort werden täglich rund 21.000
neuinfektionen gemeldet umgerechnet auf
die einwohnerzahl sind das dreieinhalb
mal so viele wie in deutschland
mecklenburg vorpommern plant deshalb
strengere einreisebestimmungen
grenzpendler müssten sich dann noch
häufiger als ohnehin schon testen lassen
bereits jetzt gehen an der rund 360
kilometer langen grenze zwei schnell
testzentren in betrieb eines davon im
kleinen grenzort linken von dort zu
seiner seite ohne negativen corona test
dafür schon lange keiner mehr nach
deutschland einreisen pendler mario
schick ist froh dass er sich jetzt
wenigstens im neuen test zentrum direkt
an der grenze testen lassen kann
er pendelt täglich nach polen zur arbeit
und braucht alle vier tage einen
negativen corona test protest seid ihr
hier
denn er hat schon gehört das land
mecklenburg vorpommern will die pendler
in der deutsch polnischen grenzregion
künftig noch häufiger testen alle 48
stunden brauchen sie dann einen
negativen test wir müssen für jeden test
zahlen die kosten werden steigen es wird
immer länger dauern den test zu machen
und über die grenze zu kommen
grund der verschärften regeln die
infektionszahlen im nachbarland polen
schnellen in die höhe
die krankenhäuser drohen an ihre
belastungsgrenze zu kommen
seit gestern haben sich dort über 21.000
menschen
neu infiziert die zahlen zeigen uns die
dunklen befürchtungen haben sich
verwirklicht jeden moment wird erwartet
dass polen als hoch incidents gebiet
eingestuft wird ab dann will mecklenburg
vorpommern die einreise regelungen für
das nachbarland verschärfen und geht
damit weiter als die bundesverordnung
uns reichen die bundesregelung nicht
deswegen haben wir hier im land
entschieden grad an der deutsch
polnischen grenze wieder stärker zu
testen die neuen testzentren sollen es
den pendlern wenigstens so leicht wie
möglich machen damit das zusammenwachsen
der grenzregionen nicht mehr als nötig
gestört wird
in mehreren deutschen städten sind heute
menschen gegen die korona maßnahmen auf
die straße gegangen auch da wo es
verboten war
in münchen wurde die veranstaltung mit
mehreren tausend teilnehmern von der
polizei aufgelöst
sie hätten die zugelassene höchste zahl
überschritten und auflagen missachtet
hieß es die bundesweiten veranstaltungen
jeweils vor dem landesparlament standen
unter dem motto ein jahr lockdown
politik es reicht unser nächstes thema
in der sendung gleich zwei bundesländer
wählen morgen einen neuen landtag auf
baden württemberg mit dem guten
prognosen für den grünen
ministerpräsidenten winfried kretschmann
habe gestern in dieser sendung geschaut
in rheinland pfalz steht malu dreyer
wohl vor der wiederwahl nach dem
aktuellen zdf politbarometer käme ihre
spd auf 33 prozent die cdu auf 29 die
afg 9 fdp 6,5 die grünen 10 die linke 3
und die freien wähler mit 5 prozent die
jetzige ampelkoalition aus spd fdp und
grünen hätte also danach weiterhin eine
mehrheit ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer
würde mit diesem bündnis auch gerne
weiter regieren aber auch christian
baldauf spitzenkandidat der cdu will den
sprung in die staatskanzlei schaffen
über den letzten tag des wahlkampfes in
rheinland pfalz berichtet susanne
gelhard
cdu spitzenkandidat christian baldauf
will alles geben bis zum schluss bildung
digitalisierung wirtschaft sind seine
hauptthemen
da kommt die masten affäre der union
ungelegen
das ist schwer zu sagen wie sie es aus
wirkt ich kann nur sagen wir haben
völlig richtig gehandelt indem wir
konsequent und sofort gesagt haben dass
das unmoralisch ist dass das überhaupt
nicht geht dass die personen auch ihre
konsequenzen zu tragen haben das ist
auch passiert malu dreyer von der spd
liegt laut umfragen vorn
die mehrheit schätzt ihre
regierungsarbeit mit der ampel aus spd
fdp und grünen
ihre themen soziale gerechtigkeit
bildung gesundheit das wichtigste für
mich ist dass die spd die stärkste
partei wird und wenn das morgen abend
sich so raus stellt dann ist natürlich
kommt alles weitere aber wir haben eine
ampel sehr gut zusammen regiert und ich
kann mir natürlich dieses bündnis auch
weiterhin sehr gut vorstellen
endspurt mit bundesprominenz robert
habeck und eine spiegel
spitzenkandidatin der grünen werben für
ein ende der klimakrise mit erneuerbarer
energie
wir kämpfen dafür als grüne die starke
stimmung in der nächsten regierung für
den klimaschutz zu sein wir wollen
drittstärkste kraft im land werden und
es ist kein geheimnis dass wir die
größten inhaltlichen schnittmengen mit
der spd haben auch fdp-spitzenkandidatin
daniela schmid kann sich eine
weiterführung der ampel in
rheinland-pfalz vorstellen
zuversicht in corona zeiten sie will vor
allem die wirtschaft stärken dann gilt
es die rahmenbedingungen so zu stellen
dass insbesondere unser mittelstand der
einzelhandel aber auch das handwerk dann
gestärkt in die zukunft geht
digitalisierung innovation ganz viele
themen die wir auch positiv begleiten
wollen
afg spitzenkandidat michael frisch wird
wohl weiter in der opposition bleiben
keine der landtagsparteien will mit ihm
zusammenarbeiten um fragen sie in die
afg einstellig er ist optimistisch ich
habe immer gesagt 10x die umfragen
deuten darauf hin dass das realistisch
ist und ich hoffe dass ich es relativ
groß werden wird es ist ein
wahlwochenende mit sturmwarnung die
ergebnisse könnten heftig wirken
bundesweit landtagswahl also in
rheinland-pfalz und in baden-württemberg
gehen wir live in unser zdf wahlstudio
zu bettina schausten und bettina es ist
auch der beginn ein
super wahljahrs unter nie dagewesenen
bedingungen auf welche überraschungen
müssen wir uns einstellen
na ja die große frage wird natürlich
sein wie sich die korona krise auswirkt
und da liegt der erste befund schon auf
der hand die amtsinhaber werden gestärkt
die wechselstimmung geht in der krise
gegen null und das kann der cdu nicht
gefallen die in beiden ländern negativ
rekorde einfahren könnte die masken
affäre die spielt dabei übrigens nur
eine untergeordnete rolle weil ja viele
schon längst per briefwahl gewählt haben
wer wird kanzlerkandidat bei der union
das thema wird die wahl morgen befeuern
und dann könnte eine politische
konstellation wieder ins gespräch kommen
die bundesweit eigentlich schon keine
große rolle mehr spielte die ampel eine
grüne oder rote jedenfalls als
theoretische machtoptionen auch für den
bund das ist eine wahl mit hohem
briefwahl anteilen das macht das
geschäft für die demoskopen nicht
leichter die forschungsgruppe wahlen die
wird aber alles geben und wir melden uns
morgen hier aus dem wahlstudio ab 17 uhr
30 mit einer doppelwahl die auch für
berlin einiges bereit hält danke bettina
und bis morgen
und heute in dieser sendung jetzt ins
ausland in russland ist die polizei
wieder gegen oppositionspolitiker
vorgegangen
nur kurze zeit nach beginn eines forums
von kommunalpolitikern nahmen die
sicherheitskräfte 200 teilnehmer fest
fast alle die sich in dem moskauer hotel
getroffen hatten
offiziell heißt es sie würden mit einer
unerwünschten organisation in verbindung
stehen
die opposition in russland beklagt dass
immer wieder gegen das recht auf
versammlungsfreiheit verstoßen wird
und jetzt nach myanmar wo die lage
weiter sehr kritisch bleibt vor knapp
sechs wochen hatte sich das militär an
die macht geputscht und genauso lange
gehen die menschen zu tausenden auf die
straße stehen mit all ihrem mut auf
gegen die hinter und protestieren gegen
brutale gewalt allein seit gestern abend
töteten polizei und armee 11
demonstrierende normen odenthal
das regime erklärt der welt sg mit
äußerster zurückhaltung gegen die
demonstranten vor
aber diese bilder sprechen eine andere
sprache das regime sagt es sei der wahre
beschützer der demokratie in myanmar
aber wer in dieser demokratie den mund
aufmacht wird bestraft der von der uno
eingesetzte unabhängige ermittler kommt
zu erschreckenden erkenntnissen in
myanmar wird gemordet zusammen
geschlagen gefoltert willkürlich
festgenommen in myanmar werden
menschenrechte systematisch zerstört
die beweise dass wir zeuge von
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit sind
werden immer deutlicher
es gibt gewalt inzwischen auf beiden
seiten aus den reihen der protestler
fliegen feuerwerkskörper flaschen steine
das militär schießt tränengas und immer
wieder auch scharfe munition
es ist eine schlacht mit ungleichen
mitteln eine kugel hat sie tue getroffen
er starb mit 37 jahren laut augenzeugen
bei einem friedlichen protest bis die
polizei das feuer eröffnete ich habe
meinem sohn gesagt dass wir keine chance
haben dass sie uns töten wenn wir uns
gegen sie wehren müssen wir den immer
schweigen alles ertragen
wir kämpfen für eine gerechte sache und
sie erschießen uns 80 tote inzwischen
vielleicht mehr
die lage wird immer unübersichtlicher
die bilanz immer blutiger kein ausweg
zeichnet sich ab kein nachgeben nirgends
von tag zu tag schrumpft die hoffnung in
myanmar von tag zu tag wächst das leid
vor knapp zehn monaten war george wright
bei einem brutalen polizeieinsatz in den
usa ums leben gekommen
jetzt bekommt dessen familie von der
stadt minneapolis ein schmerzensgeld in
höhe von umgerechnet 22 millionen euro
der anwalt der familie nannte die
einigung historisch george floyd starb
nachdem ein polizist minuten lang sein
knie auf dessen nacken gedrückt hatte
freunds ausrufe kennt brief ich kann
nicht atmen wurde zum motto landesweiter
proteste gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt
unser nächstes thema jetzt und damit
zurück nach deutschland wieder ins
museum
das geht jetzt wieder aber unter
auflagen das deutsche museum in münchen
zum beispiel empfing den ersten besucher
mit blumenstrauß
wer online vorher ein ticket ergattert
hat kann jetzt immerhin mehr ruhe beim
betrachten der kunst in anspruch nehmen
und auch im motto potsdam-museum
barberini dort ist zu sehen wie
rembrandt sich den orient vorgestellt
hat nicola albrecht mit den bildern
sie sind gekommen um ihre sehnsucht zu
stillen sehnsucht nach ein wenig
normalität nach kultur nachreisen und
dieses tor zur reise ist wieder offen
das museum barberini in potsdam das
eigentliche ziel der orient spiegelt
durch die werk rembrandts und seiner
niederländischen zeitgenossen
seine haben das gefühl jeder ein
bisschen kultur zu erleben und sich frei
zu fühlen
andere welten einzutauchen andere
kulturen wieder zu bereisen zu können
kennenlernen zu können das ist schon
eine große sehnsucht die ferne in die
eigene heimat holen plötzlich wieder
aktuell für rembrandt das zeitgefühl im
17 jahrhundert denn der meister hier im
selbstporträt mit säbel hat die
niederlande nie verlassen
wir sind hier am beginn der
globalisierung und die ferne länder
wurden überhaupt erstmals wahrgenommen
und sie kamen vor allen dingen über die
wahren dach amsterdam
so sammelte auch rembrandt orientalische
kostbarkeiten und staffierte seine
figuren damit aus seine west-östlichen
begegnungen kann jeder noch bis ende
juni erleben wenn es die incidents und
die körpertemperatur erlauben so viel
glück in einem museum
jetzt kommt der sport habe das bist du
ja und wir beginnen mit dem handball und
dem olympia qualifikationsturnier in
berlin
da hat sich das deutsche team ja gestern
ein unentschieden gegen schweden hart
erkämpft heute folgte ein souveräner
auftritt gegen slowenien entstand 36 zu
mit einem sicheren andreas wolf im tor
und effektives angriffsspiel lässt das
deutsche team den gästen eben weiß schon
in der ersten hälfte keine chance auch
julius kühn trägt bei zur 22 zu 12
pausenführung gegen die
ersatzgeschwächten slowenen dann ist
natürlich das leben gleichsam auch
richtig marcel schiller mit sieben
treffern bester werfer im team erzielt
schon nach 44 minuten das dreißigste tor
für die dhb auswahl einen tag nach dem
remis gegen schweden jetzt der sieg
gegen slowenien nach uwe gensheimer
siebenmeter zum 36 zu 27 das olympia
ticket ist greifbar
gegen außenseiter algerien genügt am
sonntag im letzten spiel ein
unentschieden zur fußball-bundesliga da
haben die münchner die tabellenführung
ausgebaut durch den sieg gegen werder
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des 25
spieltags bremen unter liegt bayern mit
1 zu 3 wolfsburg schlägt schalke mit 15
union berlin bezwingt köln mit 2 1 mainz
gewinnt gegen freiburg 1 0 ein wichtiger
sieg im abstiegskampf
das abendspiel dann dortmund gegen
hertha und bereits gestern augsburg
gegen gladbach 3 2 1 die sechste
pflichtspiel niederlage der borussia in
folge die tabelle bayern mit fünf
punkten vorsprung auf leipzig rb kann
aber morgen wieder nachlegen wolfsburg
dritter vor frankfurt leverkusen und
dort
und die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt
mit gladbach und am tabellenende haben
mainz und bielefeld vorerst die plätze
getauscht
schlusslicht bleibt schalke das
abendspiel bvb gegen hatte ausführlich
bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio um
23.30 zu gast bei jochen breyer
gladbachs sportdirektor max eberl
zum biathlon weltcup in nove mesto da
hat franziska preuß beim 10 kilometer
verfolgungsrennen den sprung aufs podest
geschafft sie wurde dritte siegerin die
norwegerinnen tiere lag oft vor dinara
allem ihr cover aus belarus die
erleichterung bei franziska preuß war
nicht zu übersehen so oft musste sie in
diesem winter trotz sehr guter
leistungen anderen den vortritt aufs
podium lassen
auf der schlussrunde der zehn kilometer
verfolgung setzten sie sich gegen
dorothea wierer und marthe und
bürohäuser land durch zum zwölften mal
in diesem winter lieferte die
norwegerinnen tieren eckhoff eine nahezu
makellose vorstellung ab mit nur einer
strafrunde gewann die 30 jährige
strahlend das vorletzte verfolgungs
rennen dieses winters wintersport auch
morgen wieder bei uns im zdf ab 10.15
vielen dank norbert gerne schaue mit
regen und schnee wird's geben keine
besonders guten aussichten von ostend
ali gleich ich empfehle ihnen das heute
journal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
gegen 23.15 heute und dann morgen am
großen wahlabend sind wir
selbstverständlich wieder für sie da
punkt 7
bis dann in allen einen angenehm
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das sturmtief zieht allmählich ab
und auf seiner rückseite kommt kältere
luft und so wird aus dem regen
allmählich schnee und vor allem an den
alpen da gibt es größere schneemengen
oberhalb von 1000 metern sind bis
mittwoch 40 bis 80 zentimeter neuschnee
möglich also schon eine große menge
schauen wir in die nacht da gibt es also
im süden schon mal regen und auch
allmählich schnee die schneefallgrenze
liegt bei 400 metern
im norden regnet es auch einige
schneeflocken sind auch dabei unter wind
ist weiterhin stark bis stürmisch teils
mit sturmböen aus west bis südwest und
die temperaturen sinken auf minus 1 grad
an den alpen im nordens 1 bis 4 grad und
morgen im tagesverlauf verbreitet
schauer einzelne gewitter der wind ist
immer noch kräftig mit sturmböen aber
nicht mehr so heftig wie heute und das
bei höchsten temperaturen von 1 grad an
den alpen und 10 grad am niederrhein
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage und da
wird es am montag schauer und gewitter
geben bei zwei bis zehn grad und ab
dienstag wird es zumindest ab von norden
her etwas freundlicher und kühler
ein schöner abend